yo represent check me out on the bootleg
Kev podcast that is it that is that hey
you're about to watch the new interview
brought to you by Blue Chu get a month
supply of blue Chu for free fellas
that's right blue.com promo code bootleg
right now get a month supply for free
helping you with that erectile
dysfunction with the same active
ingredient as Viagra and seis but you
don't got to go to the doctor it's all
online and it's delivered right to your
front door that's how we doing things
let's get into the interview
you yo it's the bootle C show holding it
down man we got a special guest here
sipping on that good Sprite to kick
things off it's
pretty Sprite pretty is that how you say
it it's pretty spell
white Byron Messiah he's here buad go
people keep [__] your name up they
keep calling you Byron msas it doesn't
matter but I'm saying is this a thing
that happen happens yeah that's a like I
I mean you know is it frustrating for
you coming to the states and like DJs
are just you know but tomato doesn't
matter tomato tomato once they know you
know once they know they know and they
won't mess up again well hey dude
congratulations on all the success
obviously talibans is a gigantic massive
smash record thanks for that um you're
from the Caribbean um which I think is
like obviously like you're from is it St
kit yeah yeah what what is it like cuz I
I've I've only been to the Dr in terms
of like islands in the world I've only
been to one Island in my life and it's
the Dominican Republic I heard I'm
slacking I heard I got to get to like
the real Caribbean I know why you was
down
there what is your hypoth why do you
think I was there why do you think I
what is your assumption on why it's it's
a beautiful place but why do you think
there I mean who doesn't want to be down
there but why do you think I was there
the way you said that I don't know
vacation maybe DJ
podcast I went there for my honeymoon
bro
okay he doesn't believe me
honeymoon it was a full moon the Dr of
course Who as a single man though huh
when you when you went were you single
like in out of a Rel I've always been
single good good for you so when you
went did you uh did you enjoy the local
talents at all I went from music bro I
don't know what you're talking about you
just looked away and then picked up a
Sprite Which is a real talltail if
you're full of [__] he's like I don't
know what you're talking
about hey this is good sprite though
when you went to the Dr did you try
mamana what it's the drink they have
it's got like a wood inside of it it's
like why it's like the drink they have
at all the resorts it's like a Dominican
thing oh no no no and then they have
their own beer El Presidente did you try
their beer no you're not a big
drinker no not really well if you were
to drink what's your preferred
alcohol um Hennessy Henny [__] I like
that that's like that 2009 energy you
know what I'm saying nobody's drinking
Hennessy anymore everyone switched over
during the pandemic they're all off of
tequila and 1942 and Don Julio such
right y yeah people I appreciate you
sticking with Team Hennessy we need more
Hennessy guys in the game right now
M um but yo tell me what what was it
like growing up in the Caribbean
man I mean it wasn't easy but it still
wasn't rough for me you know yeah yeah
always had support from Friends peers
and yeah you know family so yeah what
inspired you to uh I guess pick up the
mic start writing start rapping same
friends your friends yeah what about
like in terms of like were there any
artists that you gravitated towards s
yeah plenty who were like your like you
know cuz for me like as a kid it was
like we had like Snoop Bone Thugs 50
Eminem Outcast you know Kanye like who
were your guys when you were I growing
up listen to a lot of
Mexico popcorn popcorn you
know like Caribbean wise and there was
so many um local talents as well to you
know like from where you were at yeah
yeah school so
yeah that was basically how my whole
soul was at the time yo when they're
dancing like obviously I see videos from
Jamaica and I need to go to some of
these parties because they do that
daggering [__] where they're like what
they got the girl like and it's like
really yeah yeah I I saw did you see the
one where there was like a cinder block
involved it was like extreme daggering
like it was it was crazy nonetheless
where you're from do they do the dagger
in like at the parties is it you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah yeah dry
rating we call it you call dry rating
but you know what I'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it sometimes it looks
like it hurts like the man like it's
like you're slamming your your manhood
into like a it just looks painful are
you would how would you rate your your
your uh G rating I don't dance I Don't
Dance you don't dance no do you just sit
there I sing No but you know you got a
girl you know I me you just kind of let
her do her thing yeah I like that mhm
um what were there any American artists
that you looked up to Growing Up
yeah
um you
know growing up used to listen a lot of
slick Quick N yeah shout out to NAS yeah
slick and Nas those are two of the
school had one friend he was obsessed
with French Manana too you had a friend
obsessed with French Montana yeah so
French Montana was a must play on the
black in high school days
I got some friends from Fresno that love
French Montana yeah shout out to French
man French is one of those guys for sure
for you though like uh getting a hit in
the US and you know I always feel like
for whatever reason like the US is like
this higher standard in the music world
like I think artists feel like when they
get one here they really made it does it
feel like you're finally kind of like
making it like now that like things have
kind of like turned up for you in the in
the states I feel like we have more work
to do actually yeah you know for sure
yeah it's not a sense of oh we making it
happen but I mean I did break barriers
and I did um you know I did so much in
like six months and I'm so proud of
myself you know so I'm not even going to
hard on myself or beating on myself but
I know for sure deep down like you know
we got more work through still so it's
been a busy six months for you huh M
yeah tons of shows yeah I've seen you
get get brought out do do special
appearances and stuff what has been your
favorite live moment so far performing
[__] when Dirk brought me out when
little Dirk brought you out yeah that
had to be crazy what city was that in um
New Jersey in Jersey yeah shout out to
Dirk was for Powerhouse shout out to
Powerhouse too oh yeah that was a
Powerhouse yeah Powerhouse was a movie
man yeah that had to be a movement man
hey for you too like having burnner boy
get on the remix that's that takes [__]
to a whole another level so like I can
only imagine like you know he's kind of
like the the Jay-Z of the afro beat wave
that's happening right now which is a
little different than what you're doing
but it's still kind of got to be a big
big uh deal for you to have him jump on
a record yeah what was that like when
you first heard the vocals when you
first got the emailing your first part
ears to the remix it was not even an
email I was present you were there so he
recorded in front of you oh so you was
there yeah what was the session like it
was dark it was dark yeah but it it was
it was fun though it was exciting too
you know I was really excited like when
he started to go in I said yeah what's
his writing process like is it off the
top of the
head there no right look let me tell you
something b a boy boded that remix right
100% And I will be honest with you the
way how he came up with that verse in
that like short space of time to mhm man
this man is talented gifted like out the
world crazy insane like insanely
talented are talking about like that was
like off the like it was off the top of
the head yeah like it wasn't even
written like he didn't even stady up for
like a hour and like he went straight in
he just went in the booth and just I'm
telling you and the way how we even like
constructed the words to even be like S
is to Trinidad you know like it's
something like that is being like
thought about in the presence of course
because Prince Swan was present too from
Trinidad seeing kids and you don't know
he big up Jamaica as well too you know
100% yeah so it was it was it was a
moment like woo 100%
yeah hey shout out to Munchies our new
sponsor man first of all if y'all ain't
heard about Munchies let me tell you
they are a leader when it comes to the
hemp cannabis space they offer federally
legal products um that are very
comparable to traditional weed yeah
that's right uh and they can be shipped
right to your door no matter where
you're at and uh look this is what's
crazy we got a crazy sale going on right
now all the way till Thursday what y'all
got to do is go to delt munchies.
because what we got what we got is
award-winning Vapes award-winning
gummies
awardwinning
pre-roll not middle of the mall [__]
we're talking about awardwinning [__]
now this is what I like about these
gummies these things right here are
hitters 100 milligrams per gummy yes
that's right 100 milligrams per gummy
made with real fruit puree yes the
flavors are popping strawberry dream we
also got that appleberry nectar that
tropical passion and this is what else I
like I like these Vapes man cuz right
now you get one of these Vapes comes
with a free lanyard four G vape pen they
call it slushy juice not [__] juice
slushie juice it's live resin thcp Delta
8 four Gams in the pen I'm talking about
5,000 hits off of this bad boy now let's
open it you get the free
lanyard let's pop this bad boy open look
at that thing that's beautiful that's
beautiful right
there
oo hey that grape jelly
runs that's some grape jelly runs oh
tastes so
good God damn now look I'm telling You'
all this because what y'all got to do is
take advantage of this sale because it's
the biggest sale of the year go to delt
munchies. comom use the promo code
bootleg right now promo code is bootleg
all right go over there right now get
40% off any order $60 or more 40% off
come on man load up get something for
your people for Christmas sale ends
November 30th Delta mch.com promo code
bootleg say 40% off of order $60 or more
also want to give a shout out to the
homies in my bookie that's right my
bookie we ate if y'all did not take
advantage of that crazy deal we did last
week listen I ate bro I'm doing these um
teasers on my bookie where I put uh four
NFL teams together four NFL bets plus 13
on the teaser and we R it up right now
if you're uh doesn't matter where you
are by the way wherever you at
mybookie.ag sign up and you could get
down with me we can make some money on
the sports gambling we can make some
money on that blackjack table on that
roulette table all right mybookie.ag
promo code bootle when you sign up with
an account you're going to get a first
deposit bonus up to $200 free money in
your pocket to gamble with all right NFL
is going crazy right now NBA in season
tournament going crazy right now all
right so much going on Bowl season's
approaching college football it's going
down right now plus they just started
the ability for you to cash out your
ticket early let's say you have a parlay
six leg parlay five out of the six hit
you got to wait till Monday Night
Football to hit that six leg but you
want to take your money and go you can
casat that [__] out take your money go
home that's right mybookie.ag shout out
to them sign up with that promo code
bootleg and um you know get that free
cash deposit bonus yeah what we doing
let's get back to the interview all
right um no so for you man um talk to
talk about your uh I know you got to be
putting in some work on an album right
now yeah what is the album sounding like
and how how how far along are you with
with with finishing it well um let's get
in there let getting there you were just
listening to something right now when I
walked in so who when you walked when I
walked in you was listening to something
on your phone oh yeah that's something I
did last night with PR oh fire okay
shout out to PR from OVO right yeah
that's my boy good guy man yeah um I was
going to say though like uh how far
along you think 50% 60% um 70 70% done
mhm do we got features
yet that means
yes maybe maybe yeah um who's your dream
feature like if you had to like you know
work with anybody if you could get a 16
from somebody right now who would it be
right now
yeah
um Rod wave Rod wave would be crazy love
Rod wave he's making some of the best
music out right now he's kind of like I
feel like he's like he's like the
harmony God right now you know what I'm
saying like he does that melodic [__] on
like a another level shout out to Rod
wave um I saw recently your counterpart
bnab boy did you see the story he turned
down a gig in Dubai for because he
couldn't smoke for it was a $5 million
gig can we just make sure that you don't
do the same thing if someone offers you
5 million are we going to go to Dubai I
don't smoke you don't smoke so that's a
good thing so you're in there what's the
law about alcohol oh that you get [__]
up in Dubai for sure they give you look
okay good they give you liquor you'll be
hanging out on u i don't smoke I'm good
yeah never smoked ever so no if you
listen you could offer me 10 minut oh
yeah yeah he's like yo I'll take the
five [__] I'll take the one we'll go to
Dubai and get a meal real quick um what
what most you know obviously did you
ever smoke at a point in time in your
life of course what made you
stop I was overthinking a lot
overthinking yeah I was being too hard
on myself you feel like it was kind of
making you like like over analyze your
own [__] maybe outthink like cuz I feel
like sometimes people can overthink
their way from dropping music or
recording or being creative I used to
thought I would have never made it what'
you say I used to I I used to always be
like you know I wouldn't make it like if
you were still smoking you don't think
you would have made it no like that
those was the kind of stuff I used to be
overthinking about you know that makes
sense man trauma growing up you know
like was just too much so I just decided
you know what since you've uh obviously
been a success as you've been with the
music you got live show money coming in
you got music money coming in has there
been a stupid purchase you've made or a
big lavis purchase that you've made so
far what's the CRA I mean you got lots
of jewelry on but is there anything
crazy you you know I bought I bought I
paid off of my MMA house okay that's
that's amazing that was the first thing
I did so your mom don't have no more she
owns the crib outright mhm that's a big
deal man yeah what was that like uh
telling her that you did that was like
was she emotional yeah she was like
thank you
I would hope she would thank you
yeah hey what up y'all we got to stop
the interview tell you about our good
Folks at King pom that's right let me
tell you about King pom man it's all we
smoking over here what I love about King
pom turpine infused flavor in each one
of these These are the margarita now
this is kind of the wave I've been on
recently these Margarita ones are
[__] fire no tobacco no nicotine
straight raw organic fresh leaves um and
what's dope is they got the tip you
squeeze the tip you hit one of these
boys and you just get hit with that
flavor man you get hit with that flavor
no matter how big or small the Palm is
you know what I'm saying this is what's
dope too uh King Palm if y'all don't
know man they're one of the leading
Brands when it comes to this real like
organic smoke light that's why I like
them I like to smoke clean nothing
smokes cleaner than a King Palm so if
you're in your hood you're in your
neighborhood you're in your
[__] City your area wherever
you're at go to to your local liquor
store they're going to have King poms
all right so pick them up there you can
also go to 7-Eleven or this is what I
suggest you do right
now come on shout out to the king poms
man go to the website King pom.com if
you go to King pom.com you use the promo
code bootleg this is what we're doing
50% off whatever you order they got so
much at King pom.com not only do they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the gas
trays they got them all the cones
50% off all the smoking accessories all
the leaves you need all the flavors 50%
off King pom.com promo code bootleg also
speaking of [__] you're going to get
some money off of our family our dogs
our our listen I'm going to uh Tampa to
go DJ for these guys holiday party Odd
Socks baby the holidays are here now is
the time time to go to oddsocks
official.com and use that promo code
bootleg all right use it right now and
guess what you're going to get 20% off
at checkout now the dope thing about odd
Soxs they got all the crazy licenses
they just locked down Coca-Cola recently
yeah look at those they just locked down
Hasbro so they got Power Rangers
Transformers all that I mean look they
got cheit bro you know what I'm saying
they got Hershey's chocolate bro they
got WWE they got Breaking Bad they got
Top Ramen they got the draws they got
the socks they got the slippers they got
the Hat they got the belt whatever you
need odd Sox official.com load up for
the holidays gift odd Sox to your loved
ones whatever they're into there's an
odd Sox for it odd Sox official.com use
the promo code bootleg when you check
out save 20% off let's get back to the
interview are you going to buy yourself
a
house yeah
actually you know I'm back from s kits
yeah well they working on a project
right now so my house is already inits
it's already in the making if we go
there what is the uh Food Spot we're
going to what like the what's the
cuisine that we got to eat if we go to
St kits Boozies what is a moozy booes
booes boozy yeah well you know here we
think of boozy and we think of wipe me
down you know boozy what is a boozy oh
it's a spot that s on oh it's a
restaurant yeah what kind of what what
Cuisine is it though is it good
seafood anything good ask in the lunch
lunch time up do they got K fritters out
there the fritters that's some Florida
[__] n that's some Bahama [__] that
shit's fire you you ever tasted the k
salad no con salad no so when I lived in
Florida we had con fritters it was like
the deep fried conch and that [__] was
gas oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that
yeah they do have that back home yeah
man it's good stuff yeah so we got to go
to booes if I come out there yeah for
sure
boes uh could go by try
on the village what are the strip clubs
like there they got good strip clubs in
uh St kit yeah is it like one like the
like the spot there's two of them yeah
Club Galaxy I think we got to go to Club
Galaxy uh and I got a Galaxy you know
what I mean we got a we got a Samsung
Galaxy at Club Galaxy we be
winning anyway well listen Man album 70%
done um the record is going crazy
congratulations on the song and all the
success uh will we be getting the album
Top of the year
maybe maybe like before March you're
going to get it like either the first or
second week in January oh so it's coming
really soon mhm so yeah you I mean you
said you're 70% done you better get that
other 30 finish bro yeah you waiting on
features no all the features have been
sent in I just said maybe yeah you got
features come on man you know you got
some big features bro I doubt it well I
appreciate you Dirk on there
maybe maybe I don't know you don't know
if Dirk's on your album no he might be
that wasn't a no so we're going to just
say maybe maybe there's a 70% chance
he's on there yeah yeah okay 50 50% so
50/50 Dirks on the album yeah I'll take
that as a yeah all right well look I
appreciate you pulling up man yo we're
wrapping up an interview man of course
we want to shout out to our family at
harden baby Harden Las Vegas celebrating
their seventh birthday this month so
happy birthday to harden uh want to give
a shout out to the whole family over
there when you're in Las Vegas you got
to pull up the Hardy and tell them that
the bootleg head podcast sends you
they're going to take care of you it is
the craziest selection of Premium
cannabis in the country all Under One
Roof you walk in and it's just a Vibe
beautiful Bud tenders amazing smoke just
the illst merch you know what I'm saying
and it's right in Las Vegas right in s
City so you land in Vegas you about to
go gamble with your boys you get in that
cab you say take me to harden they're
going to know exactly where to take you
all right shout out to Hardin go follow
him hardore Las Vegas or go to the
website Hardin vegas.com